let's get more now on that breaking news
uh that the mp neil parish has had the
whip suspended following an
investigation let's bring in our
political correspondent liz bates um liz
what do we know
yes well as you say this is news that
has just emerged uh in the last few
minutes it relates to the conservative
mp
neil parish he's the mp for tiverton and
honeton
we've had a statement and we believe
this is in relation to the allegations
uh that have been uh swirling around in
westminster around who the mp
was that is alleged to have been
watching porn in the house of commons a
spokesman
for the chief whip has said just in the
last few minutes
that having spoken to the chief with
this afternoon neil parish is reporting
himself
to the standards committee of the house
of commons mr parish has also been
suspended from the conservative whip
pending the outcome of that
investigation and it's also understood
that a process has begun um
he has also been referred to the
independent complaints and grievance
system so as i said there's been a lot
of speculation around this issue over
the last few days uh in westminster and
we'll find out what happens with that
over the coming days and weeks i think